Thank You professor such for your nice
word of inter
excellencies distinguished guests
friends ladies and gentlemen thank you
propose to search for giving me this
opportunity to share with your history
with colleagues and guests my talk about
the Millennium Development Goals one of
the most difficult things to do these
days is to say something important about
the Millennium Development Goals and the
problems of poverty that has not already
been said or written by Professor fetch
having said that I wish to begin by
quoting of human familiar statistics
they are grim enough to bear repeating
anytime despite the abundance of the
world as a whole there are still 1.1
billion people living in extreme poverty
nearly three billion live on less than
two dollars a day some 1.3 billion
people have no access to clean water 3
billion have no sanitation's two billion
have no access to electricity and close
to 1 billion entered the 21st century
unable to read or write but the most are
startling statistic is the number of
people who die every year because they
are too poor to live eight millions
enough to populate a sizable national
capital it is said that statistic do not
bleed that when they are so horrible as
as horrible as these you have to pulse
and think and apart from that when you
see those video clips on TV of skeletal
babies and the trolls are helpless
hunger your humanity is challenged you
cannot avert our you cannot afford your
eyes attention must be paid
exxon's must be taken and yet it took
many years and many major UN conferences
and summit before the world community
found a way of taking concrete actions
at the millennium summit of September
2,000 in New York the heads of state and
representative of 189 governments
finally adopted the millennium
declaration and its agenda for
development that agenda called the
Millennium Development Goals are
actually all about human development and
how the human race would make a journey
out of poverty much has happened since
then with the skeptics depreciated as
just another UN declaration turn out to
be far from being just business as usual
we knew how serious was the UN system on
this matter when the secretary-general
set up the Millennium Project and hit
and had it shared by Professor Cech to
help countries toward their MDGs UN
agencies and other multilateral
institution have given top priority to
helping countries attain their MDGs many
government have successfully integrated
mdg target into national development
planning and public investment
strategies but there is a great deal of
global conference today's massive effort
financial flows for development are
insufficient and are moreover orphan
flowing in the wrong directions we do
not have an international trading regime
that can effectively open up market for
the export of developing countries some
developed countries that can make a real
difference between success and failure
in this grand and over do not have a
genuine sense of partnership with the
developing world in the asia-pacific
region it can be said that
there has been real progress toward the
achievement of the goals alongside the
robust economic growth that took place
in some countries the region has sums of
the fastest growing economies in the
world with higher domestic savings and
plenty of international results yet the
promise of the MDGs remains out of the
rich of millions many countries in the
region like the institutional capacity
to take appropriate action toward these
goals they have limited capacity to
deliver efficiently and acquit to play
the basic services needed to improve the
overall quality of life of their people
those despite a dramatic reductions of
poverty the region is still home to more
than 700 million people languishing in
extreme restitutions that is about
seventy percent of the world's poor
malnutrition persists among four hundred
million people in the asia-pacific two
of every three asian have no access to
safe drinking water of every two asian
one has no access to educate sanitation
facilities and this is the reason to
which the 21st century is supposed to
belong women and children especially in
the rural areas are still often
overlooked they should now have access
to basic health care education and
economic resources pockets of poverty
that are the result of uneven progress
should be identified and acted upon
instead of being concealed in National
aggregations this is exactly what the
leaders of Asian and African countries
agreed to do when they met in Jakarta
Indonesia in April last year the first
time the Asia African conference was
held since nineteen fifty-five this time
they issued the declarations of the new
Asian African strategic partnerships
where they agreed among others to meet
internationally agreed targets and goals
in at poverty eradication development
and growth while emphasizing the
importance of cooperation with all
regions the declarations of the rich
regional ministerial meeting on mdgs in
the asia-pacific health in jakarta early
last month also recognized these
challenges the meeting emphasized the
need for collective action while
acknowledging that attainment of the
MDGs is still the primary responsibility
of individual countries the minister's
proposed internship regional cooperation
and partnership to for achieving the
mdgs in the region with special
attention to the needs of least
developed countries landlocked
developing countries and small island
developing countries we in the region
remain firmly committed and determined
to attain our MDGs we are mobilizing
regional resources and initiatives such
as the asian development bank and the
Association of Southeast Asian Nations
to help asked word those schools we have
sought the assistance of international
financial institutions and multilateral
development agencies such as the UNDP we
have invited the United Nations system
to provide comprehensive and coherent
programs of sport for regional countries
specifically we have called on the
United Nation economic and social
commission for asia and the pacific to
help us formulate a road map to guide
our future effort as we move toward 2015
we urgently need that road map the drive
toward the MDGs had turned out to be a
complex journey
with many obstacles do the MDGs were
formulated to help all societies they do
not serve as a formula for progress that
applies to all there is great versity
among developing countries there are not
affected by the same problem in the same
way they cannot have uniform priorities
in the first place there are many
factors and combination of factors that
may have to do with the poverty of
Nations this includes a country's
peculiar geography its climate the
prevalence of disease and natural hazard
there are also political factors such as
the lingering effect of oppressive and
exploitative colonial rule the
deliberating consequences of corruptions
the nitrogens of government and the
devastation of incessant armed conflict
every national strategy for development
must therefore be tailored to the
environment of the country to each
culture and tradition as well as to its
unique resources or lack of resources
and let us never lose sight of the close
relationship between development and
security as has been mentioned by
Professor such I am convinced that the
struggle for world peace and security
will never be worn unless the chalice of
poverty has been defeated I do not have
to look too far to find a case that
demonstrate that truisms for decades the
Indonesian province of arch a small turd
in resentment you know at a after is a
province in Indonesia that was hit by
the tsunami that costs 130 thousand
lives again for decades the Indonesian
province of utter smothered in
resentment at what it perceived as an
unfair serving of the revenues from each
world of natural resource
is for lack of development the proud
encourages people of utter felt that
they were poor and did not deserve it
poverty was robbing them of their tech
native Griffin's and resentment
eventually broke out into rebellion and
sea para besoms the result was three
decades of armed conflict and while the
conflict was greeting and taking a heavy
toll of human life the prophet became
even more impoverished the situation
became a vicious cycle poverty breed
violence and the reign of violin
rendered the people even poorer in the
spirit of the reform movement that was
launched in the midst of the crisis of
1998 the government of Indonesia so to
address the problems of utter through a
dialogue and reconciliation it was not
an easy task the first attempt of both
the government of Indonesia and the
spirit is free at a movement to achieve
peace through negotiation was a failure
then came an act of God the earthquake
and tsunami of last December that way
seeded tragedy upon the province the
unprecedented catastrophe killed more as
i have said hundred and thirty thousand
people died and about 120,000 missing in
at a loon and a devastated of 500
kilometers stretch of coastline more
than half of million lost their homes it
is amazing how tragedy can make people
see more clearly the situation they are
in both the government and the free at
the movement so that the reconstruction
and rehabilitation of the province could
only be carried out successfully in an
atmosphere of peace and the only way to
peace is to make peace we made that
piece in record time and that piece is
holding the Chalin now is to make
that bitch endure so that it will become
the environment of a battle in which
former adversaries will be fighting on
the same side the battle against poverty
today to reconstruction and
rehabilitation of otter is being carried
out in a way that can serve as a model
for development planning for the rest of
Indonesia a master plan was prepared
with the full participation of the
people of the communities being rebuilt
the implementation of projects are
monitored and evaluated by the people
those the people feel that they are the
owners of their own recovery at the same
time we have put in place an airtight
system that guaranteed transparency and
accountability and the disbursement of
funds I believe that by doing so we have
been able to eliminate one formidable
Ally of poverty corruptions it was in
the spirit of reform that we were able
to address with any success the
challenges of attorney sea para patience
and development it has been the same
spirit of reform that we have been
addressing the challenges of national
security and national development since
since mid-1998 where there are Griffin
TSA's we bring justice and sit dialogue
and reconciliation we are fostering
interfaith dialogue with the intentions
of encouraging religious leaders and
scholars to take a front-line position
in the promotion right after the session
I will be attending the interfaith
dialogue that they will be attending by
wood leaders and hosted by the president
area of the Philippine Indonesia also
hosted many occasions of the interfaith
dialogue because this is very important
for Indonesia as a diverse country that
we have to bring harmony respect others
too
at the end achieved through peace in
Indonesia where there is a development
project to be carried out we should the
involvement of the widest possible
constituency of stakeholders on the
long-term we are investing heavily in
human development as reflected in our
budgetary atlas of education and health
we have in place an economic strategy
that is basically pro-growth and proper
that strategy entail strengthening of
the export sector promoting domestic and
foreign direct investment to create jobs
and accelerating the development of
rural economies we are putting new
emphasis on rural infrastructure not
nothing is too small to matter a bridge
that can cut by half a day a farmer's
track to town a schoolhouse where there
was none for miles around this make a
world of difference and the villages in
the face of the site skyrocketing of oil
prices we exercising fiscal restraint
and budgetary discipline at the same
time we are putting in place a social
safety net to protect our poor from the
rigors of this hard time especially
especially when we allow fuel price to
rise toward through market level that
social safety net will consist of
undertaking and human resources
development infrastructure building and
of course food security initially we
expect to spend 1.9 billion for this
effort to help and to protect the poor
because of the new government policy to
increase the price of the fuel the
pocket by poverty in Indonesia are
considerable we will neither deny nor
conceal these through deceptive
aggregates epistatic nor we will nor
will we gave in to despair for we have a
vision of ourselves becoming a people
that have been concurrently as the basic
problems of the human condition
we see ourselves today as a people who
have suffered much but in the process
gained a wealth of experience and
insight in the current debate on
fighting global poverty the developing
countries have argued that the developed
world are not doing enough to help
developing countries in turn the develop
will suggest that the developing
countries are not doing enough to help
themselves well I think the articles
right each of us the developed and
developing world needs to do more if we
are to tackle global poverty through
global cooperation we in Indonesia know
to address the ills of our society we
need to improve governance fight
corruption have better planning invest
more in our education and health and
utilize our resources efficiently unless
we do this with the seriousness that we
deserve international cooperation alone
will not be sufficient in the struggle
for development we know what works and
what does not work we know what it takes
to attain prosperity and that is the
continuing refinement of our institution
and human development in an environment
of democracy we believe in the
perfectibility of our democracy and in
the fruitfulness of our constant process
of reform that is a real fighting fit in
our battle cry gentlemen thank you for
your kind of fencing